lamar odom reportedly checks into rehab  I just like to say thanks to everybody I  was praying for me close to my heart  research according to reports the 37  year old former basketball pro is  receiving treatment at a rehab facility  in the San Diego area Lamar's decision  to seek professional help comes more  than a year after his near-fatal  overdose at a Nevada brothel the former  LA Lakers now ex-wife Khloe Kardashian  immediately rushed to his side and  helped him through his recovery every  step of the way a journey that was  documented on Keeping Up with the  Kardashians I was therapy today at the  end of the day I want Lamar to be happy  I still feel a ton of anxiety and  pressure but if this makes him happy and  if I could keep him safe and that's a  match made in heaven et's Kevin Frazier  spoke with Lamar in April he seemed  hopeful about his future what's next for  you Lamar um get back on the court are  you gonna try play again yeah I still  got it  [Music]  you  [Music]